one of the oldest markets in the entire
world is operating online and some say
business is hot the las vegas flea
market also operated on facebook
with thousands of users buying and
selling goods
christian casares took a dive into the
digital market
that's right brian well the flea market
is filled with unique items both new
and used from all over normally you
would need to go to a marketplace
to buy or sell goods but the pandemic
has obviously changed that
now some residents are benefiting from
it and not looking back
shopping for a great deal has never
looked so good
while las vegas flea markets are still
closed because of the pandemic
an online marketplace or la pulga as
it's known in the latinx community
has evolved it's exciting it's something
that of course it's scary
you you've got to really push yourself
to do this
um i think that the purgatory
candy flores lost her job when the
pandemic started and decided to venture
out as her own boss
so this is my workspace right here
i have my table set up for my clients
but that quickly changed when she began
to display her skills online
and word of mouth quickly spread pretty
essential i'm just kind of getting it
all together right now
since um this is something that i barely
started in this house
um so and i still need to hang
everything up and get everything
together
today the self-made business woman is
thriving and not looking back
thanks to the large network that's
keeping her busy
and that month i actually
made a little over twelve thousand
dollars she is one of hundreds that form
part of this online community of local
nevadans looking to survive
in this post-pandemic era until
traditional flea markets are allowed to
open again
patricia flores runs several independent
facebook pages which have
over 200 000 members
patricia tells us it's a simple process
where anyone can snap a picture of
furniture
clothes food or whatever they want to
sell and with the click of a mouse
the item is posted
to keep the page clean and safe the
salvadoran administrator keeps an eye
out for weapons drugs pets
and even explicit pictures
patricia says so many locals lost their
jobs on the strip and now they have
their own online store
this keeps business flowing regardless
of the language while her
fifteen-year-old son stands by
for any help they just enjoy watching
people and like they just scroll and
scroll and see something that attracts
their eye
as our day-to-day lives go online
shopping and selling
is also evolving to get you the best
deals
well patricia's flea market paige is
just one of many local groups currently
operating and folks
are loving the concept it's just
basically another way for some families
impacted by kovit
to get by christian concedes 8 news now